there's always pressure when you hit a
major league bound
particularly so when you haven't started
a game since 2018 and add in the
implications of needing a win
a lot riding on his shoulders and the
payoff pitch
strike three called joe looking for that
first
win certainly pitched well enough as
last time out get the win only won four
innings
two on nobody out for votto
and that's about alike first three of
reach for the reds
now mike moustaka stands in
and that hit him it did this will bring
in a run
that's an rbi the hard way for mustache
batter is brian goodwood
here's the pitch and he rips this one to
right field
starting in polanco has to go back leaps
makes the catch
votto will tag up at third he will score
first and second now two outs and here's
freddie galvez
payoff pitch and this one served into
left field
here comes winker around third base he
will score
three nothing reds two out rbi hit
freddie galvez
the chopper charging his mustache and
makes a nice play
about it six up six
down and here is barnhart taking his
first at back
barnhart to right field goodbye
boy did he jump on that one way out of
here into the bowtie bar
that's one of the farthest balls i've
ever seen tucker barn hard hit
the only question was fair or foul and
that thing wasn't hooking
at all straight as an arrow
swinging a miss riddle me this
third strikeout for lorenzen
fly ball into right it looks like
castellanos has it
he does and the inning is over
pretty good so far just 36 pitches
through three innings as he starts
number four colin moran batting here in
the fourth
moran sneaks it through that is a seeing
eye single with that shift the bucks on
the board moran picks up his 16th rbi
three balls two strikes one out
first and second strike three
big out for lorenzo
first pitch swung on and grounded on the
backhand to gonzales it's short and onto
first
garcia has gone one away and the one-two
pitch swung on and missed
he offered on that breaking ball and the
dirt down and away and the inning is
over
[Music]
michael lorenzen threw five in fine
fashion
michael lorenzon threw five innings and
a spot start you
a better believe congrats in that reds
dugout
four hits didn't walk a batter struck
out six
76 pitches
strength three call on the breaking ball
one out
there it comes oh got him upmc strike
zone
winker looking out at uh musgrove who
has now struck out seven
including three straight 3-2 and on the
10th pitch
he went and musgrove strikes out the
side
and coming on to make his major league
debut it is the right-hander blake
cederlin
a roll to riddle so two up and two down
in his career
and to left lake cedarland
faces three big league hitters for the
first time in his career and a little
rye
smile retires each
[Music]
yes lucas sims the new pitcher for the
reds calmly strikes out gregory polanco
to one two three seven stretch time a
great american
he strikes this one to right center
that's gonna drop in for a hit go to the
wall extra basis for gonzalez
he'll drift into second base he has a
double with one out here in the eighth
payoff pitch
[Applause]
fair ball heads up play by barnhart
grabbed it in fair territory a tag of
haze middle the eighth
still 4-1 all right red's trying to
protect a 4-1 lead
in the ninth amir garrett on the hill
he has no saves in his big league career
and this one caught
a leaping catch at the wall by brian
goodwin
well colin moran hit it hard but he hit
it very
high and he gave a chance for the center
fielder goodwin to get over there now
you got to time it just right
yeah that's a great catch garrett always
with the theatrics
three walks all year two walks back to
back here
cole tucker with one home run this year
three balls two strikes
one out runners on first and second
swing out of this he struck him out
not yet appearing in the batter's box
we'll see if there's a pinch hitter
it'll be newman now the 3-1
in the air
aquino has it in the reds
hold on to win 4-1 it's their fourth
straight victory overall
the first major league save for amir
garrett